author bio
be alone that is the secret of invention
be alone that is when ideas
are born nikola tesla
first things first it shouldn't take 28
years for a human to discover the first
principles of consciousness and
metaphysics
we need incentive architectures and
systematized processes for new life
birthing at the base camp to rock it out
to the edge
in these fields what do you say when a
16 year old
asks you how can i become a polymath
why do we not have a genius olympics
that's as popular as the world cup
art distillations the shortcut
is to study the most uncommon geniuses
that have ever lived
synthesize and distill their wisdoms not
into a 500 page book
but rather 20 images 21st century style
the future of communication is highly
visual especially the most abstract
meta patterns in 2015 i started asking
the most profound questions i could
think of
in 2017 i started a show called
simulation interviewing the greatest
minds
in 2020 i finished high level perception
in 2021 and beyond we have moved our
show to los angeles and are focused on
asking the biggest questions to the most
famous people to accelerate the
awakening
we are also producing an animated series
on metaphysics
and anthology several documentaries
and working with some of the best talent
to do so
i will continue serving as a steward of
high level perception
and rich patrons for the next years to
come to architect the more beautiful
future our hearts know is possible
by 2024 i would like to be filling
sports stadiums for full day events
catalyzing the evolution of
consciousness
and architecting the genius olympics by
2032 i plan to run for president of the
united states
inclusively stakehold everyone and
nature working with the best teams to
maximize unleashing the gifts of every
soul
more esoteric i think my sole angle is
to come to planets at pivotal points in
their trajectories
to parse their repositories find the
highest level patterns
and tell stories via art that accelerate
their awakening
my body of work continuously helps
conscious agents optimize their
strategies for simultaneously merging
into the ocean of oneness
and expressing their unique gifts sri
aurobindo nailed it with diversity in
oneness is the mathematics of the
infinite
donald hoffman and his team are the
closest i can tell right now that are
actually doing the math to prove the
conscious agent metaphysics
i will be publishing more projects
specifically elaborating on the concepts
brought forth in high level perception
i am now living proof inspiration and a
mentor for others to carve their own
path
reach out i'm happy to field questions
collaborations podcast
speaking requests high level perception
gmail.com
follow along across youtube twitter
instagram linkedin
every decision directs the cosmic telos
unrealized potential is our biggest
problem
on genius deadline completion be dumb
enough to constrain yourself in a
burning building with no exit
be smart enough to figure a way out of
the puzzle
eric weinstein
you